- Hey, Legal Eagles, I
thought I would take a break
from your regularly scheduled programming
to give you a sneak peek of my new office.
As you can see, it's filled
with many leather bound books
and it smells of rich mahogany.
A couple of Eagle-eyed
viewers, pun intended,
noticed that the books had changed
in my regular shooting location.
And it's in locations like this
that I plan on shooting a whole bunch
of new videos in 2021 in
ramping up production.
And speaking of which,
only until January 1st
can you get 41% off of
CuriosityStream and Nebula
where I put extended
versions of all of my videos.
So check that out and as always,
I'll see you in court
or in this office.